[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good evening.
Yes.
And welcome to the
Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study at
Harvard University.
As Faculty Director for the
Humanities at the Institute,
I'd like to both thank you
and to congratulate you
for coming to this
event, which I
think will not only
be illuminating,
but also great fun.
My name is Shigehisa
Kuriyama, but only for a few
more minutes.
[LAUGHTER]
For over the course
of the next two hours,
I've been given the opportunity
to become someone else, someone
new, someone whom I've never
known in my 64 years on Earth--
[LAUGHTER]
--and yet someone who
has doubtless been
within me all along, waiting
for this evening with you
and the magic of talented
transformation artists, who
are with us tonight.
So tonight you'll get
a chance to witness
this transformation live
not only in me, but also
in Professor Robin Bernstein--
[APPLAUSE] --current
Radcliffe fellow
and Chair of the
Department of Women's
Sexuality and Gender
here at Harvard,
and was gamely agreed to
join me in this adventure.
Harvard professors in drag.
[LAUGHTER]
Who'd have thought it?
[CHEERS]
But then again, why not?
It's an experiment.
And frankly, nobody knows how
exactly it's going to turn out.
But as you track our
gradual metamorphosis
into people whose gender
will probably seem much less
clear than they
seem right now, I'd
like you to bear
three things in mind.
The first, and probably
most important,
is that Robin and I
are basically you.
We're merely stand-ins.
And in observing the changes
that we are undergoing,
you have to imagine
yourselves being transformed.
You must imagine
yourselves exploring
the possible selves within
you that have not yet
been realized.
The second point that I'd
like you to think about
is the remarkable power of
the art form known as drag
to spotlight the enthralling
complexity of human identity,
how the many different
permutations of sex, sexuality,
and gender take on
infinite gradations
as they become combined
with the performance
and the communication of gender.
This is one of the central
lessons of the wonderful 2017
documentary called Kings,
Queens, & In-Betweens,
around which this evening's
activities are organized.
And we're privileged and
delighted to be joined
this evening by Gabrielle and
Jen Burton, two of the five
sisters who produced this
film, as well as five drag
performers, some of
whom actually you'll
see in the film.
So here's the
trailer for the film.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- When people think of sex and
gender, it's black and white.
Drag is a way to
show the gray areas.
Because it's not
black and white.
It's never been black and white.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The root of a lot of
violence and bullying and stuff
like that is not about
sexual orientation,
it's about gender identity
or gender expression.
- So I can have a
different gender
identity from my
physical sex and that
has nothing to do with who
I want to have sex with?
What?
- I'm a teacher by day
and a drag king by night.
- I'd go to the Royal
Renegade's shows.
I thought it was awesome.
But I said there's no way in
hell I would ever do that.
I would never glue
hair on my face.
- All of a sudden
some of the people
who voted against gay people
having the same rights
as straight people in the
state are saying, well,
why can't Julie have any
time to stay with her family
when you had a baby?
They have that feeling
of like, well, I
would never want you to not
be able to be with your son.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I know that my parents saw a
very different picture for me.
I think they wanted me to go
into politics and be a lawyer.
They also saw me getting
married, having kids.
I plan on having a
white picket fence.
I plan on having children.
But I plan on doing
it with another man.
- Oh, no, I mean, the
only time we have sex
is when it's in drag.
No.
- Do not use that.
That is so not true.
- [LAUGHS]
- That will never happen ever.
- I had to sit down and ask
my bro, like, how to be a guy,
like, how to walk like a guy.
- I'm a trans guy.
I'm doing theater.
This isn't drag for me.
- I don't think
being a man is bad.
I don't think being
a woman is bad.
I just happen to be
really in the middle.
- A drag show in Ohio?
I didn't even know there
were 400 lesbians in Ohio.
- It's OK to be who you are.
I mean, that's what
it's about, not
being afraid of
being who you are.
- I don't have to be a man.
I don't have to be a woman.
I just have to be me.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
- So in a few moments,
Gabrielle and Jen
will speak to you in greater
detail about the movie
and the interplay of gender
and drag performance.
And you'll be treated to
some terrific performances
by our artists.
But I want to conclude with a
third and more general lesson
that the encounter with
drag might teach us.
And that's a lesson
about latent,
unrecognized possibilities.
And here I'm going to
introduce something
that I'm sure you never
expected in an event on drag.
Drag invites us, I
think, to ask what if?
What if we tried something
that we never, not only never
tried before, but never
even thought of trying.
What wonderful new truth about
the world, about ourselves
might we discover?
Now, I want to illustrate this--
and this is the
unexpected part--
with a simple example
about something
that probably most
of you have never
tried and certainly
not tried in connection
with reflections on gender.
The thing I have are paper.
Everybody has paper.
Everybody's handled
strips of paper.
But have you ever thought
about the potential
of two strips of paper?
Think, you could have all
sorts of associations.
One is sex, sexuality.
One is John and Joanna, John and
Mary, the body and performance.
There are all sorts
of things that one
could associate with these two.
Now, if you were to take
a strip of paper and glue
them together and then cut
them, what would you get?
You'd get two rings.
Everybody knows this.
But here's something that
probably you have never tried.
Suppose you have two strips and
you glue them together and then
what you can do--
let's see here-- in terms
of unexpected possibilities.
This is something that you
can try at home, right?
It's PG.
No, no, you can do it
with four year olds.
Sorry.
So you're going to
glue one and the other
so that you end up
with two rings, right?
Simple enough.
Definitely try this at home.
Now, before, if we had one
ring and we cut it apart,
you know you get two rings?
What happens if I now
take this and split
this does anybody know?
Again, it's not something that
you do every day, you know?
It's not part of
your daily practice.
Oh, let's see if I can cut this.
You get one ring, four
rings, anything else?
Any other takers
before I finally--
So we have four rings, you have
one ring, but what do you get?
You get a square.
[APPLAUSE]
Who'd have thought it, right?
So we had two straight
rings, and we got this.
I just wanted to show.
I just sort of lost track.
See how user friendly we are?
We want to make sure that
you're able to do this at home.
So you just saw the result.
Now, we're going to
a second possibility.
So now you get,
oh, maybe there's
something more to these
ordinary strips of paper
than you thought.
And you think, OK,
now I know I can
try something different, which
is you take two cross strips
and you make one ring, but the
second time you add a twist,
right?
You add a twist.
So again, you can imagine, OK,
sex, sexuality, John and Jen,
there are all sorts of
variations you could think of.
So this time, instead of
just two straight rings,
you're going to get
one with a twist.
So what is the result
of that process?
Any takers here?
- A tetrahedron.
- Tetrahedron?
Somebody who knows a lot
about geometry, but not really
about sex.
[LAUGHING]
So again, don't
take my word for it.
Try it.
What you get,
interestingly enough--
whoops-- is again, you'll get
a square, even with a twist.
So final experiment-- think, OK,
that's been going pretty well.
This time we're going
all the way, right?
We're going to go and
make two interlinked rings
with one twisted toward
the right and one
twisted toward the left.
What's going to happen?
- A square.
[LAUGHING]
- Oh, OK.
So, a pessimist.
[LAUGHING]
[INAUDIBLE]
It doesn't look like it's
going to be a square.
What is it going to look like?
Let's see.
Just got a little-- oops.
My finger is stuck here.
If you unfold it, what you find
is basically two linked hearts.
And I think this
is a good lesson.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, what I'd like you
to think about is this,
paper is such a simple thing.
It only has two sides.
Anybody can use this, right?
Human beings are so
much more complicated
than a two-sided sheet of paper.
Think of the possibilities.
So that's one of the
themes of this evening.
I'd like now to turn it
over to Jen and Gabrielle.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much, Hisa.
That was so wonderful.
So I'm Jennifer Burton.
And this is my sister
Gabrielle Burton.
And we are two of
the five sisters.
We have a company Five
Sisters Productions.
We've made seven feature films,
many commercials, shorts,
and including many that look
at gender from different angles
and perspectives.
We've made the MTV
LOGO film Happiest
Day of His Life, which is
the picture-perfect wedding
all gender reversed.
We're making a series of short
films called Half the History
on the under-told stories of
women in American history.
We have a new film coming
out that's about parenting
and gender.
And, of course, Kings,
Queens, & In-Betweens.
Tonight, I also wanted to add,
is a particularly celebratory
night.
We're very happy to be kicking
off the 2019 conference.
And also tonight one
of our performers
in the film, Nina West, is
premiering on the RuPaul drag
show.
So that's exciting.
- Hashtag teamnina.
So we made this
film because we were
interested in capturing gender
diversity and the complexity
of gender performance
both on and off stage.
Drag is a perfect window to open
up these questions about how
we define identity in our
society, how we might get
beyond the binaries of, say,
male-female, straight-gay,
masculine-feminine and
instead create space
to recognize the complexity
of all of our humanity.
Using music and
costumes and movement,
drag goes beyond words to
explore new possibilities
for the aesthetics of gender.
And so much of gender is
communicated non-verbally.
We'd like to start
by introducing you
to some of the performers
we were lucky enough
to be able to film for
Kings, Queens, & In-Betweens.
I need to remind you that
Harvard's campus is cash free,
so you have to
refrain from tipping
these performers tonight.
So without further ado, here are
members of the Royal Renegades
the Reverend Roy Rogers.
Twinkerbell--
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHING]
I'll read all the
names, then you can--
Twinkerbell, Topher Wright,
Dr. Cool Ethan, Jaden Jamison,
and drag queen Anisa Love.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- As so much of drag is
about transformation,
we'd like now to invite our
two professor volunteers up
to begin their transformation.
[CHEERING]
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
So we have Hisa Kuriyama
and Robin Bernstein
to start, who will be here.
And as we start
the transformation,
we're going to be showing
the first clip, which
is seven minutes
long and lays out
some of the issues
about drag and gender.
So we'll get you set
up with your chairs.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- For me, it's not
about gender, at least.
- I think it's easy for him to
say that it's not about gender.
Because I don't honestly
think in his mind
it is about gender at all.
I think, like, but I don't
think that drag from the outside
perspective cannot be about
gender in our society,
whether it's
subconscious or not.
Like, I feel like it
says a lot about gender,
whether it's meant to or not.
- Because when you get on
stage for drag and I say
I'm Toe B, a drag king,
there is an expectation
from the audience that
I look like a man.
And then I get judged
on how masculine I look.
I like to blur all that stuff.
I like to be feminine and
masculine at the same time
because there's a whole
continuum of where
people are in terms of gender.
And so I want to
mix all that up.
- It's a complicated
issue, because I'm
dressing like a woman.
But really, I'm not really
If you think about it,
it's such a character.
You know, it's big
hair, pounds and pounds
of-- tell me what woman
wears that much makeup.
- Gender really is this
made up thing in our head
to keep everybody in order.
That's all it really is.
It doesn't even make any
sense, no sense whatsoever.
Not every girl looks
good in pastels.
- For gay men, I'll
say that I think
it's very difficult to live up
to a standard of what you think
masculinity is supposed to be.
There's this kind of
like Will and Grace
style gay man that's,
like, everybody's best
friend at the office, you know?
And I don't know that there's
quite that lesbian identity of,
like, oh, you know, like, that
the straight guys at the office
are going to be like, oh,
my best friend is a lesbian.
I'm going to take her to, like,
get some power tools with me.
- Oh, no, the flip
side is the coach.
- Right.
- You know, or the
beast, you know?
The big old coach, butch
woman who's, you know, scary,
scares everyone.
- I remember when I was 13,
I had to ask my brother,
literally, I had to sit
down with my brother,
who is a football-playing,
you know,
beating up people guy
and lifting weights.
I had to sit down
and ask my bro,
like, how to be a guy, like
how to walk like a guy.
And I remember him sitting down
and showing me how to walk.
- It's like you raise your
eyebrows and you smile.
Hi, oh, there's a
little baby in here.
Oh, that's so cute.
I mean, you know, and
if you talk like that,
people are going to
be like, oh, well,
this person has to be a woman.
- I couldn't tell
you the first thing
about how to do like boy stuff
like fix a car or, you know,
fix a computer or
anything like that.
- That's not necessarily
boy stuff, though.
- This is how I'm comfortable.
I'd rather not wear baggy
clothes and backwards hats
and polo shirts.
That's me.
This is how-- No
one criticizes me
for the way I dress because
I pass for what feminine
is supposed to be.
- There actually is a moment
in the film Paris is Burning
where one of the characters
is talking about wanting to,
like, knowing that he wanted
to be a woman because he wanted
to like wear frilly
underwear and carry a purse.
And I'm like, well, I'm
a woman and I've never
worn frilly underwear and
I don't carry a purse.
- Some of our greatest
chefs and cooks are men.
But at the same time, they'll
tell you in the household,
in a heterosexual
relationship, it
should be the woman that cooks.
Now, how do you
make sense of that?
- You know what?
I'm a guy.
And I am feminine.
And I have the right
to be feminine.
And there's nothing
wrong with that.
And I am a guy.
I don't have to be your
stereotype of a guy.
Even in the trans
community, there's
a lot of expectations there
of what you're supposed to be.
And I have people
telling me all the time,
why are you messing it
up for the rest of us?
People look at you and they
see you with your pink hair
and acting like a girl
and that tells people
that being a trans guy isn't
real and that you're faking it
and that you're messing it up.
And then it's like, what can
you say to that except I'm just
trying to live my life.
- The root of a lot of
violence and bullying and stuff
like that is not about
sexual orientation.
It's about gender identity
or gender expression.
I mean, cultural expectations
that, if you have a vagina,
you will be a female.
You will then have a
certain kind of femininity,
and then, you know, certain
jobs and certain power dynamics
and certain relationships to
someone of the opposite sex who
has a penis and all
of the expectations
that go along with that.
And people who don't follow
those rules get pushed around.
And it happens on the
playground when you're five.
And it happens in the
corporate world when you're 50.
- But the binary of
gender maintains things
like the census, where
you have to pick,
are you a man or a woman,
are you male or female.
But there are
obvious alternatives.
Like, we could ask
people, where do you
sit on the spectrum
or a continuum
between masculine and feminine?
- Super feminine, super butch,
I think there's a lot of us
out there that just kind
it fall in the middle.
- What comes to mind for
me is going to the bathroom
in a public place as a woman
who reads as masculine often,
I've had years of stares and
gasps and, [GASPS] are you
in the right place?
You know that kind of thing.
But no woman responds
with violence towards me.
They respond with like
shock or something.
- You kind of watch
over your back
to see what's
happening behind you,
you know, if you're walking
down the street, you know?
Even though nothing would ever
happen and nothing ever has,
you always are kind of keeping
an eye open, you know, to--
- I wouldn't say
nothing ever happened.
- No, I mean, you know,
people will yell something.
But I'll tell you--
- You got egged.
- But not in drag.
I think you have more
problems just as a gay man
than you do as a drag queen.
- When people think of sex and
gender, it's black and white.
And for me, drag is a way
to show the gray areas.
Because it's not
black and white.
It's never been black and white.
- The really fun part of
drag is playing around
with what gender can mean.
I can have, like, a
package in my pants
and still not be bound.
- You can be this masculine
person who is this
male-identified character,
yet the male character that
you're identifying
is really femme.
- Once he starts singing, it
drops all gender barriers.
- It's the freedom of drag.
And I don't have to
be a man to do drag.
I don't have to be a woman.
I just have to be me.
And I really think that's
what the essence of drag is.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
- Thanks.
This conference is about
gender and communication.
And we're so happy to
be here with Kings,
Queens, & In-Betweens and
some of the performers
who were in it.
It took us over six years
to make the movie because we
wanted to get it right.
And in our film
company, we sisters
have often thought
about the issues that
are communicated through media
about gender, what subconscious
and conscious
messaging is telling us
through those images.
There is a fundamental
question about identity,
how we communicate
identity beyond words
and how our cultural
presumptions, stereotypes,
and traditions play
into that, either
influencing or reinforcing
what is being communicated.
Drag shakes all that up.
It shakes up a binary
system that is often
imposed upon our thinking.
Drag makes us
question what we see,
what we perceive in the
layers of what we might know
or what we actually
think we know.
The communication of
gender within drag
is completely up for grabs.
Now, not literally, though
that does happen at some shows.
But gender and identity and drag
are not defined or communicated
through clothing, hair
quaffing, or other indicators
that we typically stereotype.
Drag uses its art
form to shake up
the whole idea of what it
means to be female or male.
And within an LGBTQ
performing space,
it also raises questions of
how we communicate sexuality.
Is it on the surface?
Is it in our swagger
or in our engagement
with an audience
who knows perhaps
how we represent ourselves
outside of that space?
Recently, the #MeToo movement
has brought communication
and gender to the
forefront, gathering
the strengths of millions
of individual voices
and amplifying their gendered
experiences, helping them to be
heard as a group, in strength.
Ultimately, for Jen and
me, all the performers
of this who are here
tonight, questioning
these assumptions is the
key, questioning ourselves
and raising questions
perhaps in the conversations
we have with others.
And there's also then the
celebratory acceptance
of welcoming in not defining
others, of welcoming
in one's own self definition,
whatever that might be,
and of all of it
being OK because we're
each masterpieces in the making.
Drag communicates that to
the audience, that that's
what we are, whoever we are,
and whatever experiences
we might be having
in life or have had,
whatever pain we might
be in, and the joys, too.
This is an art form
that celebrates
the beauty of every
person and connects us
into one fabric of humanity
because this is who we are.
And here's Anisa Love.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The Wednesday night show
is, like, a big rotation.
So since there's so many
drag queens in Columbus,
it's just kind of who is
selected and who is performing.
It's a very straight crowd on
Friday nights, which we love.
But sometimes it takes
them a little bit longer
to get into it.
Because they don't know
us, necessarily, you know,
personally.
And then Saturday
at 6 o'clock it
starts getting really rowdy,
then 10:00 is really crazy.
And then Sundays are
just really drunk, so--
[LAUGHS]
- [INAUDIBLE]
- That's bullshit.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
It's bullshit, too.
- Oh, no, that's
just-- he's just--
- [INAUDIBLE]
- Isn't that painful
in your hair?
- Uh, no, not really.
Because the sweat
takes everything away.
But it's a little tight
right now because I put it
on a little too tight.
Wasn't paying attention.
- Beverly, look at this.
Look, come over
here and show her.
Show her.
Her balls are inside of
her and they're like this.
Show her.
- No!
- You look like the
Terminator right now.
- Terminator or Predator?
- Your skin is all shiny.
Do you think that the
celebrities in Hollywood
use PAM to take their
faces off at night?
Does Richard Chamberlain use PAM
to take his face off at night?
- [INAUDIBLE]
- Love you.
- Where did I put my shirt?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Have a good night, guys.
- Our chariot, our
Lamborghini awaits.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
- You can see from
that clip how hard
work professional drag can be.
And you can make money.
But there are certainly other
easier ways to make a living.
So what draws people
to perform drag?
The answers range from
self-expression to politics,
to community.
And when we have a
Q&A, you may want
to ask some of the performers
what brings them to drag
and what drag means to them.
In thinking about
tonight's event,
I was also thinking about
what draws me and my sisters
to explore gender in our work.
It took me way back to when
we were children growing up
in Washington DC and my parents
joined the feminist movement
in the '70s.
My mother went from a
traditional housewife
who dressed up for
going out in a bouffant
and in pearls and heels.
And she went from that
to giving up skirts
for jeans, having
long hair, no makeup.
Now, this was just at the
time when my sisters and I
were starting to
enter adolescence
when she was
consciously giving up
all of the traditional
trappings of femininity.
So what it did for
us is we started
equating traditional
gender expression
for women with sexism.
And we developed this
sort of secret code
amongst ourselves that was
really a rigid policing.
So there was no
makeup, of course,
no twirly skirts, those were
definitely bad, no shaving,
which was hard in a
large public school
system, and no dangly earrings.
I still remember the moment
that my sister Maria, who'd
grown a little
bit older, and she
insisted on buying these
Snoopy earrings that
fell just below the earlobe.
And it felt as if so
much was at stake,
that this decision could
start everything crumbling
and lead to her ruin.
So fast forward to graduating
from Harvard Radcliffe,
I majored here in drama
before they had a drama major.
I did a special concentration
in non-verbal communication
in theater.
And I ended up
getting a fellowship
to go to Japan to study
traditional Japanese theater,
Kabuki and Noh.
And there is a very
strong tradition
of drag in the national
theatrical tradition of Japan.
So one of the first dances
that my kabuki sensei
taught me is "Sakura."
And he taught it to me as a
female, which is very small
and in.
And you do these
kind of movements.
And you speak in
a very high voice.
And then he taught
it to me as a man.
And it's open and
big and loud and low.
And over the course
of the year, I
realized that I
didn't want to be this
and I didn't want to be this.
But I was somewhere in between.
And studying this
theater for a year,
it gave me the ability to decide
myself about gender in my life
and work without listening too
hard to what others, including
my mother, thought about
the way that one should be.
So my son and daughter
are growing up now
in Brookline where they have
a dizzying number of options
for how they want
to look and act,
which carries its own
difficulties for adolescents.
But the key difference is that
they are navigating at a time
when we are developing
the words, when we
are finding models for being.
What I, as a child,
vigilant about
the dangerous slippery
slope of dangling earrings,
could never ever have imagined.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- So sex, gender, and
sexuality, I got it?
- Yes.
- Everybody has a sex, a
gender, and a sexuality.
And they're mutually exclusive.
One does not dictate the other.
- Sex, gender, and sexuality
are three separate things.
- Like, oh my god, so I
can have a different gender
identity from my
physical sex and that
has nothing to do with who
I want to have sex with?
What?
- OK, so sex is
your physicality--
I'm a man or a woman.
Sexuality is who
am I attracted to.
And then gender is everything
that is socially constructed
around me.
A woman should be very
feminine and everything that
represents feminine.
And a man should be very
masculine and everything that
represents masculine.
- Maybe they were born female,
they're transitioning to male,
but they're attracted to men.
Then a lot of people
would say, well,
then why wouldn't
you just stay a girl?
And then you'd be normal.
And that's not how
it works either.
- I don't know I don't
think that any one person is
necessarily gay or straight.
I don't think any one person
is necessarily male or female.
I think you have traits of
both involved in everybody.
- I don't think that
it would be impossible
for me to date a man.
In fact, I can see it happening.
But it wouldn't
be a straight man.
It would be like a gay man
or a transgendered man.
Like I could
definitely see that.
- I have only and still have
only dated straight guys.
I don't consider myself--
I consider myself
in the gay community
because I support
the gay community.
And I'm definitely a huge
fan of the gay community.
But I consider myself--
I'd like to say straight.
- I am in a relationship.
I'm in a 15-year, I
think, relationship,
been married 11 years,
with a born female who
does not necessarily see herself
as a lesbian or even gay.
It's just me who she fell for.
- I think most people label me
as queer because I am attracted
to so many different people.
- And in the male gay
community, are you welcomed in?
- Yeah, but, I mean, there are
a lot of gay men, obviously,
who want somebody with
biologically male parts.
But there are a lot
of men that just
want that masculine
physique that, you know,
if you've got that, it
doesn't matter what you
have underneath your clothes.
- I recognize Kristin as a drag
king when she's performing.
But, I mean, I like
that she is a girl.
[LAUGHING]
- We have people who are
women, who identify as women,
and their bodies represent
womanhood to them.
But then they get
with someone on stage
who they're partnering to
make it a straight couple.
But then queer people are
watching that and seeing it
as a queer relationship.
They don't be like, hey, look
at those straight people,
this is hot.
They're like, I
know that those are
both girls I think that's sexy.
So the way the desire is
placed on drag performance
is one of the most
fascinating things.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
- So now we're going
to check in with--
[LAUGHING]
You can keep working.
Keep working.
[LAUGHS] So I have a mic
coming up, I believe.
- I swear I'm not going
to knock your eye out.
- Just going to do
a mic for Robin.
Here they come.
Here we are.
Oh, here they are.
My mistake.
So Robin, I wanted to ask, what
is this experience like so far?
- Well, I haven't seen myself.
I have no idea what I
look like right now.
This is definitely
the most makeup
I've ever had on my face.
[LAUGHING]
- So would you like to talk
a little bit about sort
of in terms of--
[LAUGHS] I'm so distracted.
[LAUGHING]
I think I'll go over on
this side for just a second.
[LAUGHS] Hisa, what do you--
[LAUGHS] what is this
experience like for you so far.
- Uh, looking good is hard work.
[LAUGHING]
- That is for sure.
So Corey, could you talk
a little bit about--
- What's happening right now?
- Yes, what kind of things
have you been working on?
- Here, I can hold it
and you can keep working.
- Perfect.
Well, it's really weird.
Because when you try to
take a masculine face---
I will say this now, Asian
men are perfect specimens
because you already have these
beautiful high cheekbones.
- Hey!
But normally, when you're
trying to take a masculine face
and make feminine features,
it takes a lot more work
and chiseling.
We don't have that kind of time.
So we're just making
shit out of Shinola.
It's going to be beautiful.
He'll be delicious, I swear.
[LAUGHING]
She gonna be so purty.
- Hisa, was this sort
of what you exp--
I mean, when we pitched
this idea to you, did that--
[LAUGHS]
- He said, ah, no.
- Did you have any idea?
- I had no idea.
I had no idea that.
But it's great.
[LAUGHING]
- That's what they said
on the Titanic, too.
[LAUGHING]
- OK, we'll come on over here.
So tell me a little
bit about what you've
been doing to transform Robin.
- So typically there are certain
features that is typically
a stereotype of masculine.
So what I'm trying to do is
paint Robin's face in a way
that you are seeing
the furrowed--
men tend to have
that ridge and they
tend to have more of
a pronounced nose.
So I'm trying to bring those
features forward using makeup.
- Interesting.
OK.
And do you have a plan for
any facial hair for her?
- Yes, it's coming.
- No, no, no.
I know, I was just
going to see if you
wanted to talk about that.
Because this is our check-in,
sort of what your plan is.
[LAUGHING]
I was not saying
you're behind schedule.
[LAUGHS]
- Yeah, so there will
be facial hair as well.
I have to set the makeup first.
Then actually, the
facial hair is just the--
I guess, the, you know,
topping on the cake.
But essentially, the makeup
forms the foundation for you
to create those features first.
So without those
features, facial hair
really doesn't do much in
terms of the transformation.
So I need to set the face first.
- And then we asked Robin
to do a little preparation
for the facial hair so you
could talk about what you did.
- Oh, sure, well, I got a
haircut and saved the hair.
[LAUGHING]
So I've got a Tupperware
right over there with my hair.
And I had to chop
it up really fine,
which took a really long time.
So that's where
it's coming from.
- So then it will all match.
OK, so basically, drag involves
many different types of gender
and physical transformation.
And these can include binding,
tucking, packing, facial hair,
clothing, wigs, and so on.
So while our amazing
professor volunteers
are getting their
final transformations,
we thought we would show you a
five-minute clip that gives you
a little insight into
what courage it took
for them to accept
being here and part
of tonight's performance.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I had seen Virginia West
perform before I knew Chris.
And then when I saw Chris
and met Chris and talked,
and then I found out
he was Virginia West,
and then I saw Virginia again.
And, I mean, it
just blew my mind.
I still have never seen
him actually tape up
and everything like that.
I've seen him take it off.
But I've never seen him tape up.
I don't know that I
necessarily want to see that.
- I don't think anybody
should ever see that.
- I think it seems
like, to me, that
just feels like mutilation.
Like, that just
looks like it hurts.
I'm not interested
in seeing that.
I mean, there's many
times where I would
like to inflict that pain.
But-- just kidding.
Just kidding.
There's gonna be so
much things that--
- Well, I don't--
I think-- You said--
do you think I tape?
- I don't even know.
I don't even know.
- Because I don't.
- I don't how it happens.
- I don't actually, I know a
lot of drag queens will tape it,
but I don't.
Because I wear pads,
hips pads, and I
wear so many pair of
tights that, you know,
I don't have to do that.
But that would be pain--
I can understand why
that would be freaky.
- Like, for me putting the
balls up inside of you,
does that not happen?
So you have your ball
sack hanging down?
- Wow, we're getting
real-- real--
- Well, see, like,
this is obviously not
going to be a PG documentary.
But, like, I mean, that
just seems like it hurts.
- They naturally go in there.
- No, they don't on me.
They don't on me.
That hurts.
- I have a thing
with my partner.
He doesn't love it.
He appreciates that
he knows that that's
how he met me and he
knows that's what I do.
But he said, "how long does it
take you to get out of that?"
I said, "about 10 minutes."
He goes, "can you
cut it to five?"
- When it comes to binding,
some people use an ACE bandage.
- I tend to go
with the duct tape.
Other people have
full outfits they
wear underneath their clothes.
I don't know what
they're called.
- Post-surgical-type
compression vests that really--
it's like a whole sort
of shirt that you wear.
- ACE wrap is the worst thing
that's ever happened to drag,
even though it's like
a staple for drag.
I mean, I use it too.
But really, one, you
can't dance in it.
You bend over, you do
any of these things,
and it's going to roll down.
And you have to
duct tape your skin.
And it's cinches
your ribs and it
can constricts every time
you breathe because it's
supposed to be compressing you.
- [INAUDIBLE]
- OK, go easy there on my back.
- OK, so we just
need to come around.
Because what happened is--
like, this happens with me, too.
It'll start pushing up too much.
And then it looks
really weird and lumpy.
- I don't know.
We like that.
- But we like a
little bit of lump.
- You're doing it a
little rough today.
- Go ahead and spin.
- I thought you liked rough?
- Man cakes.
- Ready?
We're going to end it here.
And then what we're going
to do is put a shirt on
to see how it looks.
'Cause she's good at these.
I don't like that on me.
But she likes that.
Tony Walnuts, he
likes that on him.
- I'm sorry I have
the biggest pecs.
- I don't know, you're
like a Jersey Shore guy.
So we'll readjust it.
Cause it's a little lumpy.
But when you put a
shirt on over the shirt.
- Yeah, I think we
need a little bit here.
- OK.
- You know?
It's going to get my armpit.
It's fine.
- All right.
Many, many, many a night do
I cut this off of my skin.
I've had like
scratches on my body.
My back has literally
bled from the marks
from pulling this off.
- OK.
That's good.
I can breathe, but not as
deeply as I used to be able to.
- All right.
- That's good.
- Looks good.
- Thanks, bud.
- It's sort of like a tank top.
And then it pulls all
the way down to here.
And they also make ones that
are short that are just here.
And then it just smooths
you and flattens you out.
And when I had a bigger chest,
when I first transitioned,
I was like a D. I
absolutely refuse
to wear a tight binder
all day because--
So this one is significantly
tighter and it makes me
like super flat.
Then you do the
classic binder hop.
Any sane person isn't going
to wear this for very long.
It's better than an ACE bandage.
I mean, ACE bandage
is a nightmare.
It cuts into your skin.
- Do you know
where my socks are?
- The binders cut
into your skin, too.
- [INAUDIBLE]
- But like, it's
just not as bad.
And it distributes the
pressure so much better.
So you know, if you're
just bound up here,
it, like, really
wrecks your lower back.
- [INAUDIBLE]
- I'm taping the fat away.
[LAUGHS]
- So how does that feel?
- Oh, painful.
It's terrible.
It's the worst part.
Yeah.
Yeah, no peeing for the
rest of the night now.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
- So I think we need to get
just a little bit more time in.
So we're going to go a little
bit off script here and ask
Ethan Balk to come
to the stage to talk
about something, an issue that
is interesting in the idea of--
[APPLAUSE]
--of gender and sort of
going beyond words and that
isn't about tipping.
One of the interesting
experiences
that we had in making
the film was one night
I was going to go film Ethan
performing in this big contest.
That was Nina West, so
you think you can drag.
- Oh, thanks.
- Thank you.
- And it was an interesting
moment as a documentarian
because I felt a need--
it was in a gay bar
and I felt a need
to tell Ethan about
something that I had observed
gender wise about the
way tipping was done
and was accepted.
And so basically,
I went up to Ethan
and I said, hey, you know,
you're going into this gay bar.
And one of the things that
a lot of the kings did
was taking the money and sort
of throwing it off to the side.
And I said that's not the
way that men in that space
actually address money.
And there is this moment
that's very shared.
And part of it, it
seemed to me, had
to do with lesbians demanding
money of other lesbians coming
to see the show, which was a
different economic situation.
And so the whole layers of
politics, economics, and gender
came into that.
And I just wanted to have you
talk a little bit about that
and how then you were
able to incorporate that
into your performance in that
space, which was phenomenal
and he won.
[LAUGHING]
All because of that.
[LAUGHS] No, so first of all,
when I did this competition,
this was years before
I decided to start
testosterone and transition.
So it's great, you know,
it's fun to watch the film
and see myself.
And I'm like, oh my god,
I look so tiny and young.
So it was such great feedback.
And it was something
that I had not thought of
and had been doing while
performing, you know, as a drag
king, as a drag queen in spaces
that were comfortable for drag
kings to perform.
Because really before I
had done this contest,
there wasn't a mix yet.
There was drag kings
doing stuff over here
and drag queens doing
stuff over here.
And this was Nina
West's first, you know?
She was like, I'm going to
do this drag competition.
And I'm like, well,
I'm going to do it.
So--
- You were the first drag king.
- I was the first.
Yeah, I was the only drag
king in the competition.
And I was psychotic about it.
You could ask my wife
about it, who's back there.
And before, you know, I was
upstairs, I was practicing.
Before I went on,
Gabrielle was like, listen,
I noticed that Chris and Andrew,
Virginia and Nina, when they
go to take a tip, they connect.
They connect with
the person, right?
They look them in the eye
and there's this exchange.
And it was like,
[IMITATES EXPLOSION] I
was like, oh my god.
And so I did that.
And that's probably the
reason I won, I guess.
I don't know.
- No, it's because
he was so good.
- No, but I did that.
I did that, and it
changed the game for me.
And from then on, I don't
know why there's probably
a lot of gender structure into
why I did not feel comfortable
doing that, but at that
point, then I was like,
oh my god, I had no idea
I wasn't doing that.
And so then, you
know, from then on,
we just did it a different way.
- I think to me
what I observed was
there was a socioeconomic
different reality
in these different spaces.
So some people had a lot more
disposable income and cash
and higher incomes, and
other people who didn't.
And so within the club where
the kings often performed,
that was not as high a
socioeconomic audience.
And so the idea of
then expecting people
to give you money was sort
of a demand on the audience.
Where it was appreciated,
but it wasn't--
- Emphasized.
- It wasn't, you
know, put in that way.
But then additionally, I
thought, and you can correct me
if I'm wrong in
this interpretation,
but the idea of how a
man would handle money,
being given it from
somebody, and being
strong in that expression, was
about, hey, I got this money,
but it's just, I
don't need this.
I'm going to throw
it back there.
Because it's just
like small change,
whereas in the other space
every dollar matters.
And that was sort of what I
call the stripper moment to you.
You have to have that
connection of this is my money.
I'm buying something
from you for it.
And when you're made
to feel like the center
of the world in that space, it
had a different feeling, right.
- Yeah, and I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to interrupt you.
- No, go ahead.
- I'm learning.
Because now I present
as a white guy, so now--
[LAUGHING]
Let me just mansplain
this right now.
[LAUGHING]
You know, it was almost, like,
when we would take the dollar,
I bet there was
something where it was,
like, I don't know if
we really deserve this.
Thank you so much
for doing this.
This is so silly.
And I don't think that
was the same way as how
males performing felt.
So it was a good--
- Yeah, and in this
one tiny detail,
it was something
that I felt you were
going into this other space
and was important to know.
So it was sort of this
interesting ethical moment
that we had talked about,
do I say something,
do I not say something.
- As a documentarian, yeah,
you don't want to interfere.
- Do I just observe it or
do I change the reality?
And so I felt it was
an important thing
to sort of build a
bridge between these two
communities, which then
happened after that show,
is that Ethan started
getting invited
into the shows in that
space, and so did Becky.
And then it became this
kings, queens thing.
And now the that
space incorporates
gender queer performers and a
lot of, well, what would you--
I mean, some kings sometimes.
And whenever you come
back, you're in the show.
- Yeah, it's the whole spectrum.
- Yeah.
- There's more kings now.
There's kind of gender
queer, in-betweens.
There's guys that are dancing.
There's girls that are dancing
and they identify cis gender.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so something
about that spectacle, when
you have everyone
up there onstage,
that makes it even harder to
sort of define and quantify,
right?
And also even the
mixing up, like,
I have a colleague who performs
sometimes as a bearded queen.
And so mixing up even
within your character
that you're taking
on, having it be
this sort of giving very,
very strong gender cues,
but of different genders.
- So how are we doing?
- So let's see how we're doing.
- We'll have a check-in.
- Hey, you guys, how's
it going back there?
- How's it going?
OK, so why don't we
open for a question?
[LAUGHING]
- It's going well.
This is how it goes back stage.
You just never know.
- We've gone fast.
- That's right.
So we actually are
ahead of schedule,
according to our thing.
So we can ask a
pre-question before the Q&A,
if you want to, if anybody
has anything for now.
Please.
Yes?
- So what got you into drag?
- Me?
- Oh, good question.
Oh my gosh, that's so great.
We were going to talk
about that later.
OK, so, god, it's this whole
evolutionary thing, right?
So it's, you know, when I
first started doing this,
I hadn't started
testosterone yet.
I was still OK, I
guess I'm a lesbian.
And that's the two choices I
have, besides the other choice,
that was clearly
not working out.
So, you know, I've
always loved theater.
And it's always been
a part of my life.
I wish it would have been more.
It's been a part of my life
where it was like, I love this,
but I don't want to
be a girl on stage.
So it's like, OK,
what am I going to do?
I don't know, I did
the backstage stuff.
And then I did, kind of like
some roles where it was like,
OK, well, you're not the pretty
one, you know, or whatever.
And, you know, that just
opens up so much conversation
around the only roles that
are available for women.
And how it's, you know, if
you look any sort of different
from the main role, you're maybe
the funny one or that's it.
You know, you
don't get the part.
So I love that.
And you know, I kind
of started doing
some sort of sketch
comedy in a queer space.
And one of my drag
queen friends needed
a sidekick that was a guy.
And so I kind of
started doing that.
And then, you know, it
just sort of took off.
And before I did, you know, the
whirlwind sort of competition
with Nina's competition,
I did this small kind
of drag king thing.
And so that's where I met
Becky and Kristin, the Rev,
and Topher Wright.
And it was this moment where I
got to be a creative director.
And I got to be the guy role.
And I got to do all of
these different things.
And, you know, if you would
have ask me 5,000 years ago when
I started doing drag, you
know, why did I do this?
Well, it's because I
got to do the guy thing.
But, you know, if you
fast forward 12, 15 years,
I got to learn so
much more about me.
And, you know, my wife
and I have two children.
And what am I going
to be for them?
And, you know, I think I
should start testosterone.
I think I should do this.
And it's such a hard question
that I get these days.
You know, why do you do this?
And it's like originally,
I had this idea.
But now it's because
I get to stand up here
and I get to talk to people
about how there is so much
gray in the questions that
we expect to be answered
in black and white.
And if I could just
show people that there
needs to be no boxes, right?
There needs to be no--
there's no yes or no.
It's this gray kind of thing.
Then I feel, then that is
what kind of completes me now
as a performer.
- Excellent.
- Great.
Woo-hoo!
[APPLAUSE]
- So, all right, I think
we're good on timing.
So thank you all so
much for coming tonight.
We're looking forward
to joining you
at the rest of this conference.
And we're going to close
this evening with a film clip
from Kings, Queens,
& In-Betweens,
which you can get on
iTunes and Amazon,
that touches on how
drag as an art form
shakes up as our assumptions
and presumptions.
And, in doing so, it does help
us break down those barriers
that Ethan is talking about
to build new social groups
and towards building one
community of human beings
all together.
So we'll then have, after
the clip, our closing
number from our wonderful
performers Anisa Love, Topher
Wright, Dr. Cool Ethan,
Jaden Jamison, Twinkerbell,
the Reverend Roy Rogers, and
our new special guest stars,
War and Peace and
Queen Shesahesa.
[LAUGHING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I think when people
mess with gender in public
and perform that, I
think that's always
empowering for people
in the audience
to see the possibilities.
- We, as a country, put so
much emphasis on who we should
and who we shouldn't be around.
Why not just go out
and be able to meet
those people that you wouldn't
necessarily ever talk to?
You know, at work, you
know, where I would work,
you know, people never had an
experience with drag before.
And now they come
constantly to the shows.
You know, so I think by
doing that, you open up
people's minds, you
know, to realize
that everybody is just human.
- How many straight
people are here
tonight, ladies and gentlemen?
[CHEERING]
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
to our straight
friends for coming out and
supporting the gay community.
[APPLAUSE]
- The straight crowd has really
revitalized the art form.
And being embraced
by straight people
has not only challenged
their viewpoints,
bit it's also challenged ours.
- For me, it's nice to look
out and see that there's not
a divide between the gay and
the straight, it's everybody's
mixing.
And everybody's
there for two hours
really enjoying
themselves and not
caring that they're
in a gay bar.
My straight friends, they
all come, they love it.
They have so much fun.
And they're always like
shocked that, you know, wow,
you look so--
I mean, I look 100%
different as a girl.
Like, you would
not recognize me.
- I think it really breaks
down, little by little,
every bit of stereotyping
there is and every bit
of divide between the
two communities of being
gay and being straight.
And I think that's
what we should do.
- OK, well, I don't approve
of gays, but I love you.
You know, so that's
how it kind of starts.
And then it's like, well,
I don't approve of gays,
but I love you and I
love her, you know?
And then it just
kind of spreads.
- You know, so I think
it's breaking down.
- I think what
really helps is also
they have a strong pour
at the bars, which--
- Yeah, some people get drunk.
But hey, listen--
- --it loosens it up.
- I don't care how you lose your
inhibitions, just lose them.
[END PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I'm so tiny you
can't even see me now.
[LAUGHING]
It's like a very dark shadow.
- Here, I don't
want that to break.
You are amazing and I hope
that you win tomorrow.
- All right, Roger.
- So Ethan, you mentioned
that through drag it
helped find yourself
and it helped
you start transitioning more in
a deeper personal sense, as you
started doing a
gender transition.
Well, I wanted to
ask, do any of you
know anyone else that
drag has aided when they
weren't otherwise aware of how?
But, you know, has aided in
starting their transitioning?
- If you watch the movie,
the black transsexual Akasha,
I don't even know if she said
this in the movie or not.
Before she ever thought
that there was transsexuals,
because I was her
drag mother at first,
she was just this
cute little boy that
would come to see me at shows.
And she said there's
something about this that
is moving me in this direction.
And literally, I was with
her when she went and got
her first job done,
her booby job.
- I would say there's a lot of--
I watched drag kings go
through this as well, you know?
You know, this is
like a 10-year period.
So I got into it.
I met guys that had
already transitioned.
I met women that were thinking
about it and then transitioned.
And so I think this is a
very raw environment where
you get to see what's
going on outside of you
and then decide I don't know,
I think that might be me.
And, you know,
you get to realize
all of the reasons
that maybe led
you to do this in the first
place, for some people, right?
- I've been fortunate to
compete in the pageant systems.
And, I know--
- Talk a little bit
about that, like, what
is the pageant system?
- A drag pageant is
like drag on steroids.
We, like, you know--
- Or estrogen.
- Or, like, we fight with
rhinestones and glitter.
That's what we do.
So it's like a system
where you compete
in different categories,
evening wear, talent,
on-stage question, interviews.
This is on a judging scale.
So, I mean, it's your
resources and time and money
that goes into it.
It's a serious thing.
It's like sports for drag.
So I've been fortunate that
I've met a lot of drag kings
who have competed at that level
who have since transitioned.
And I think it's a safe
environment for them
for them to do so.
And it's that period
of which, you know,
it's something they
can try on and decide
whether at the end of
the night, it's something
they want to keep continuing.
Or, you know, like, when
I leave here, you know,
I take my boobs out
and I'm perfectly fine.
But for others, it's one
of those things where
they're like, oh, maybe I want
to keep my boobs taped up.
And so that's when that
starts that journey for them.
And it's a very supportive
environment for them to do so.
Does that make sense?
- Thanks for that.
- Yeah, thank you.
- If I could add onto that, I
think it's an interesting issue
to talk about the idea of
transitioning that, you
know, what is that definition?
What does that mean?
And do you have to go from
one binary to another?
Or does drag just open
up a space for you
to find who you are?
And I think that
that's something
that is powerful about
it to think about.
- And if you didn't already
know by the last names,
Ethan and I are
husband and wife.
So to expand on that, Ethan had
top surgery about 10 years ago.
- Years before.
- So, you know, when we talk
to our parents' generation
and talk about my
mom said, oh, should
we start using male pronouns?
And I said no, you
know, at that time,
Ethan was Liz using
female pronouns.
And I said, she just doesn't,
you know, identify with them.
And so she just, you know,
wants to get rid of those.
But we're not, you know, we're
not talking about testosterone.
- Just get rid of those.
- Yeah.
[LAUGHING]
- [IMITATES SLASHING]
- Come on, cuteness.
I'm looking right at you.
- All right, thank you.
Thanks for being here.
I really enjoyed myself.
I have a financial question.
What's the cost of
entry, costumes, makeup?
And does that become
a barrier to--
- Millions of dollars.
- Does that become a barrier
to who can access drag?
- That's a great question.
- I will start.
I will say that things have
changed since I started.
This is my 19th
year of doing drag.
Whatever, catch me at 20.
Catch me at 20.
Sometimes, because I look at
it, it's a business for me.
I love the art of everything.
However, there is an investment
that I've made in the money.
And I have a book.
And I'm still old school.
So I have a book,
an actual book.
So I know from every
show I've done,
the amount of money I've put
in and the amount of money
I have received, and
that will counteract.
Now, I'll be honest, this dress
that is excessively too short
that I never tried on was $200.
And clearly I'm going
to find another time
to use this dress with
a big Harvard H on it.
But you have to think
about the cost of makeup.
You think about duct taping,
binding, transportation,
all of that goes in.
But I have turned it into--
I'm an individual
sole proprietor.
So I am a whiz at tax deduction.
Trust me.
And obviously, Virginia was
the one that got me there.
Because I was just spending
thousands of dollars
and knowing in my mind it
was coming back in cash.
But I had nothing to show for
it but more glittery things.
I bought a home with drag.
I paid off my college
loans with drag.
I'm trying to buy a
new car with drag.
And this is now a
part-time job for me.
So I have other income.
But it's my love.
Because I get to meet you.
And so at the end of
the day, the money
doesn't outweigh the
joy that I get to have,
regardless of the intake,
do you know what I mean?
So I still get this
beautiful connection
with each and every
one of you because we
have this moment tonight.
And it would never
be captured again,
where I'll make some
more dollars another day.
You know what I mean?
So money will come
and go, but this stuff
is the best part
about all of it.
[APPLAUSE]
- To answer that
question, I mean,
yes drag is an investment.
But you slowly
build your tool box.
That's what it is.
You don't drop a whole--
because no one gets into drag
thinking I'm going to get rich.
No.
So you slowly learn to
build your tool box.
Like, I didn't go out and buy
the most expensive makeup.
You know, I started
off with CVS makeup.
And then I cut
corners where I could.
- Goodwill.
- Honestly, like, Goodwill
is the best way to do it.
- Goodwill.
You know, if you learn how
to tailor your own clothes.
I'm the size of a
10-year-old boy.
And, you know, like,
I learned how to sew.
And you know, I only
need one yard of fabric.
So that costs $5, you know?
And everyone thinks
I'm a wizard.
I'm like, no, it
only cost me $5.
- We share a lot.
You know, like, we share
costumes, share facial hair.
I mean, a little bit of Becky's
facial hair tonight, you know,
is mine.
So like if you're fortunate
enough to start doing drag
where you become friends with
the folks you're doing it,
you get to know them.
I mean, the resources
in the community
and with, you know,
YouTube and all the things
that the kids are
doing today online,
there's just so many resources
I feel like out there
that have helped, at
least in the past 15 years
since I've been doing drag.
- And another thing is if
you are fortunate enough
to receive enough visibility,
you end up with sponsorships.
I'm actually sponsored
by TransTape,
who buys all the tape I need.
Anytime I need tape,
they provide it for me.
So I'm starting to get people
who want me to, you know,
use their products.
- I think that drag is also
a mentorship community.
And so there is a culture of
perpetuating, bringing people
up through the
education process, the,
you know, people all have
a drag mom, drag dad.
People all have drag babies.
You know, it's a true family.
And the tradition of kind of
that culture of bringing people
up, and so you kind
of learn those tricks
as you're coming up with
the help of your elders.
- Yeah.
- Hi, my name is Amanda.
I use they/them pronouns.
And I'm very comfortable
saying that because I
think I was very
fortunate to be exposed
to that when I was quite young.
My question is for
the entire panel,
but I think specifically
perhaps for parents,
what do you hope that
these types of movies
will do for the next generation
of young folk being raised
as if this is their norm?
- Oh, I can start that question.
Because one of
the reasons that--
I think I'm wired, actually--
one of the reasons
that I made the film,
and when I pitched
it to my sisters,
was that I went to
a drag show which
the couple that was in the clips
that you saw when they were
talking about, "I don't
know if you tape it,"
and they were having
that whole conversation.
- The balls.
- Yeah,
- That's my best friend.
- Yeah, the bald guy is
my close friend, Seth.
And I had known him
in a writing group.
And then he invited me, he said
do you want to come to a show
that my husband's in?
And I said, oh, sure, you know,
be supportive of your husband.
And then it was this
enormous drag show.
And his husband is one of
the top queens in Columbus.
And so it was just an incredible
variation of performance
and exciting and
splendid and spectacular.
And yet also I had toddler
children, a son and a daughter.
And in technicolor up on stage
was being played out the issues
that I was thinking about every
day of how they were being
immediately gendered into
these binary camps and given
expectations and
toys and, you know,
from being hairless
babies in a yellow onesie
and how people would
have their expectations
they put on them with
whatever biological sex
they thought they were.
And so I went home and called
up my sisters and said,
could we make this documentary?
And I think it'd be
really a great window
into talking about this.
And the impact I
was hoping to have
was to actually talk about
this to open up possibilities
for parents and children and
people to sort of self-define.
And I said it would take
us six months or something.
And then it took 25 years.
- Hi, my name is Priscilla.
Welcome to Harvard.
I'm delighted that you guys
are here, all of you are here.
My question is about health
care, access to medical care.
And there's so much in the
news about these backroom
operations, going into a
hospital, not being accepted,
either you or your partner.
Has that changed?
What's happening in
that whole realm?
- So I'll just talk
about that for a second.
My wife and I have
been married for--
- Uh-oh.
- 25 years.
- That's so typical.
We've been married for years.
We were living in Ohio when
we had Lyla, our daughter.
And I'm not on her
birth certificate.
So I was fortunate
enough, we had our baby
at Ohio State, which is a
very inclusive environment.
So I was fortunate
enough to be there.
This was before I had
started testosterone.
So Mara and I were two
moms having a baby.
And they were very sweet.
And, you know, Mara took
on a lot of this herself
because she knew how
upset I was about it.
But I wasn't involved
in the conversation when
the social worker comes
into the delivery room
to sign the birth certificate.
And I'm still not on the
birth certificate for Lyla.
So that was difficult, you know?
That was very hard.
And the opposite
of that was really
upsetting to me when I had
started this transition.
And for our second child,
Amos, who we call Tuggy.
When Tuggy was born,
it wasn't a question
because I was just
presenting as something else.
And it wasn't a conversation.
And it was upsetting
to me because I
had gone through that
whole thing before.
And now there was
just this assumption
that, sure, you're involved.
And, you know, you're
obviously the dad.
And, you know, you
can be on this now
because it's OK because
you're presenting one way.
So it was very tough for myself.
But I have to
credit my wife, who
I've been married to for years.
[LAUGHING]
- The difference was also
that, first of all, when--
Lyla is 4 and 1/2.
So she was born before
DOMA was passed.
And so that passage
provided a whole slew
of rights for our
friends in Columbus.
And then we moved to
Connecticut two years ago.
And there was a conversation
with our son's birth.
And because the birth
certificate asks,
do you know the child's
biological father?
And we had a long conversation.
We went back and forth.
The social worker made a bunch
of different phone calls.
And then she finally was
just like, yes, yes, yes
is the answer.
Because whether or not Ethan was
presenting as male or female,
we didn't have his sperm.
It wasn't--
- There isn't any.
[LAUGHING]
- So really quick, because
you mentioned the back-door
operations.
- Yes.
- And I'll just speak.
And look at that, I'm the
black person on the panel, too.
I've had many sisters pass
away because of the surgeries.
That's something
that needs to be
regulated, especially within
the south, which is very odd.
But, like, within
south Florida there
was just a transsexual
woman arrested because she
was doing injections.
And those illegal injections
caused multiple deaths,
two of which were
my personal friends.
Well, one of them, I'm wearing
her earrings right now.
Taneesha, she was amazing.
So it's hard when you're already
an entertainer by yourself
to get health care.
That's something
that you're going
to have to spend money
on COBRA and you're
spending all this extra money.
So, for example, the nightclub
I worked in years ago, actually
right around the same time
the movie was being filmed,
I severed one of my toes,
a tendon in my big toe.
And I had to pay for
that out of pocket
because I didn't
have a full-time job.
Because at that
point I was still
running around auditioning as
a singer and doing all this.
So years of me trying
to pay for this surgery
that the company I worked
for wouldn't cover.
Cut to now, and I'm
in a different life.
And now I'm using Anisa
as a source of income plus
my full-time job offers
me, all-inclusive me--
I could be on the stage
and break something
and my health insurance
from my full-time job
will cover it regardless.
So it's really with
time and acceptance.
However, we need to legislate
all of the legalities.
Because no matter
what we find, there's
always going to be someone else
who wants to try it cheaper.
And sometimes cheaper
is not better.
And I am a budget bitch.
I am the first
person that will see
through a way out of something.
But it's not my health.
Lord knows, it
won't be my health.
What's going on?
- Oh, you know what?
Let me add really
quick one thing.
The movie is being used with
medical conferences now,
actually, as an education tool.
So that's been really exciting.
Because it's been proven
effective as a way to,
not necessarily for just
trans people, but the idea
of doing gender performance or
presenting in a different way
and what could be a way
to educate caretakers
on different modes that people
might be dressing or presenting
themselves and the health
implications of that.
And so that's been an
exciting part of progress.
- OK, thanks again
for being here.
My question is about
the mixing that
was mentioned with the
Nina West competition
where you have a traditional
drag queen space now filled
with performers and a
broader gender spectrum.
Have you found that that's
promoted a deeper understanding
of intersectionality?
And is it translating
into coalition building
and other aspects
of the community?
And I'm particularly curious
about the straight audiences
that are coming, maybe for a
spectacle and a stiff drink.
Are they turning around
and then supporting you
at the community health center
fund raiser and the ballot box
and that sort of thing?
- I can say, and I'll
speak just for quick,
I'll make it really quick.
Nina is one of my best friends.
To be fair, we started doing
drag the exact same day,
exact same place.
And I just took another
name, she took West.
It has been amazing
over the past 20 years
to watch the crowds
go from all gay men,
and then, right
around the late '90s,
like, I would say
early 2000s, there
was this amazing
group of lesbians
that started showing up.
Then they started--
Then they started telling
their straight friends.
And my mother was
at every show I
did when I first started
because she wanted
to make sure my hair was right.
Trust me.
So now we have these amazing
partners across the globe
and across the spectrum that
are they are cheering us on,
giving their money.
And they're using their voice
to help us raise awareness
and funds for health care.
In Columbus it's Equitas who
does every part of any health
care a person needs,
from Planned Parenthood
to everything.
And in Columbus, we've
raised over $2 million.
And we would never have
been able to do that
without straight people coming
to every one of our shows
and giving their money.
Last week we raised $7,000
and it was 15 minutes.
$7,000 and 15 minutes
on a Sunday show.
And all of that money went
to the Mosaic Project,
which is a form of Equitas
Health, which that money will
be moved towards transgender,
non-binary, people of color,
of youth.
And that's the only
program like that.
And then the other
half will go it's going
to the Ronald McDonald House.
And I'm fortunate to
live in Columbus still,
to where we can make
all of this money
and still help our community.
So at the end of the night, I
can put my head on the pillow
and know that we've done
something wonderful. .
And that would never happen
without straight people.
- So, yeah, we have
time for a couple more.
So we should--
- Hi, my name is Patrick.
Thank you all so much
for being here tonight.
My question mainly goes to
the producers of the film,
but this can be addressed
from everyone on the panel.
But I'm thinking
specifically that it
is 2019, which will mark 50
years since the Stonewall
Uprising.
And I think it's important
that we honor our trans
and queer women of
color who really
launched that fight for us.
- Mother Marsha.
- And so I think it's--
Marsha, Mother
Marsha, that's right,
and Sylvia and Miss Major.
But I also am
wondering, too, with
this particular
documentary, which
I think the clips that we've
seen have been wonderful.
And I noticed that a couple of
times in the film that Paris
is Burning was mentioned, which
largely featured folks of color
in the ballroom scene,
things of that nature.
So I'm wondering, as we
think about drag today,
how are we continuing to
honor those initial authors
of that culture in a way that
can still kind of center them
and sort of honor them
today, especially as we think
about how far we've
come as a movement
as we continue to
honor our trans
and queer folks of
color ancestors.
- Really quick, only because--
That's, A, point on.
In Columbus, we're
still in Ohio,
so you have to really
understand that there are not
very many African-American
people of color that
are performers.
And I'm not saying
the level where I am.
I am one of the most
visible people of color
you will see in the state
of Ohio only because I'm old
and I'm very outspoken.
So when the movie was filmed,
since this has launched,
there has been this resurgence
of all of these amazing queer
people of color that are walking
and giving life and living just
like I did when I first
saw Paris is Burning
and I was definitely a teenager.
So now, like, we had a ball.
We had a ball.
And we brought in--
Jesus, there were like
four different houses.
And to be fair, my drag
mother is a Balenciaga,
if you know anything, Raquel
Lord, Balenciaga, from Atlanta,
is my drag mother.
So we had this amazing
ball at Axis Nightclub,
which 10 years ago, would
have never happened.
Because if you weren't
at tweaky white kid,
you would not have
been accepted.
And then I turned the corner
and walked into my home
and saw all these beautiful
shades of brown, yellows,
white, and it took me
back and it made me cry.
Because the work that we're
all doing is making this
happen on an everyday basis
in every one of our towns.
So it's happening.
It may not happen as
fast as you want it to.
But bitch, it's happening.
- Yeah, I wanted
to add one thing.
- Can I--
- Yeah.
- Oh, yeah.
- I do recognize,
as a POC performer,
I think, it's especially
among drag kings,
I think I can count seven
Asians in the United States drag
kings.
And I understand like, a
little bit about my background,
I'm from a [INAUDIBLE] family.
You know, grew up with that
cultural, you know, stressors
that I had to be
feminine, passive.
And so I do this because I
want to be visible for others.
And I take that seriously.
And so this is
why I go out there
and do these educational
things because they're my jam.
Just So that others can see
me and they can feel welcome
into the scene.
Because sometimes it can
be especially as a king,
it can be somewhat intimidating.
And especially these are
spaces, you know, ran by men.
You know, so as a drag
king, it's even more,
I bear a greater responsibility
being a role model out there,
just being visible.
- We see you!
- So in producing
the film, one thing
that was really
important to us was not
having mediators,
sort of talking heads.
Or there was one idea that
people came in and said,
well, why don't you
sort of say, what
was your experience, Gabrielle,
coming into this community
and what you learned.
It was really important to have
people speak for themselves
and have their experiences and
show how complex they were,
that there was one part of
the structure of editing
which is that one person will
say a definitive statement,
and then often there's
other people sort
of saying different
things, and so
showing all the way
through the film
that there are many voices.
And it was important
to us to represent
the range of people
who are performing
and have them speak
in their own voices.
And I think that that's part of
the educational mission is also
then having these conversations
so that people can see
themselves on screen and
also then maybe continue
to learn about the history from
seeing what's happening now
and how it's changing.
- Yeah, and we stand
on the shoulders
of all those activists who have
come before us and everything.
And the history
that Radcliffe is
about preserving and
exploring and all
of these realms of
intersectional being.
And I think that the
kings and queens and trans
and other gender
performers in Columbus
often actually
mention that at shows.
And we certainly feel that us
five sisters in filmmaking,
that we stand on the
shoulders of the women who've
come before us.
And hopefully, we'll be
lifting up other people
in the future on our shoulders.
- Where can we see the movie?
- Oh, you can see the
movie on iTunes or Amazon.
So, yeah.
- I'm going to try to move this
without breaking everything.
OK.
Hi, I'm Jack.
My question was that as a trans
masked person who has also
really always been interested
in drag and like drag king
performances, like
all that good stuff,
I find myself like caught in
this other, like, bogus binary
of authenticity
and artifice, which
I think becomes coded, right?
Because like sexism as
masculine and feminine,
like masculine as
authentic, feminine
as artificial and fabricated--
And like, I love drag because it
then takes it and is just like,
well, everything is authentic
and nothing is authentic
and everything is
artifice and nothing is.
So it's this awesome
like post-modern thing.
But how do you engage
and hold, like,
that performativity and
artifice as like an extension
or a [INAUDIBLE] of the
idea of authenticity
when it's like on your
body or in a community.
So the person who was talking
about the gate-keeping that
happens in the trans
community sometimes around
like, oh, you're ruining
it for the rest of us.
When so much of our lives
is dependent on, like,
living our most authentic self,
right, that's the branding,
how do we then love
artifice and love drag?
- Oh, interesting.
That's a great question.
- Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
- I could--
- Yeah, go ahead.
- I was just going
to say, I mean,
for me, I feel kind
of most in myself,
I feel some of the most
authentic in those moments.
authentic when I can step up.
You know, when, I was younger,
I literally had no friends.
I spent years of my
life eating lunch alone.
And in this family, being
able to step into these roles,
I'm able to practice, you
know, radical inclusivity
by seeing people
and by really trying
to like connect with everyone.
Tonight when I was in the
audience giving hugs to people
is because I, just like what
we were talking about earlier,
it's those connections
that are so important.
So to me, I think take a
deep breath, step into it.
And there is no greater time,
when I am at my full true self,
when I'm standing up blasting
in this costume I feel like it's
me turned up to full blast.
- To 11.
[LAUGHING]
- Robin and Hisa,
do you want to talk
a little bit about the artifice,
now that you're in artifice.
I mean, what would
you say to that.
I think that's an interesting
question to throw to you.
- [CLEARS THROAT]
[LAUGHING]
I think one of the things
that strikes me is really
the importance of mirrors.
Because I actually, I
mean, I had the experience
of being dressed
up, but I actually
have no idea what it looks like.
- We purposely kept
the mirror away.
- Should we bring the mirror?
Should we bring the mirror over?
- Would you like to see?
Here.
- Yeah, like legit has no clue.
Got dressed in the
dark, has no idea.
- What about you, Robin?
Have you seen yourself?
- I would like to see myself.
- Wow.
- Right?
- [LAUGHS]
- Hey, girl.
[LAUGHING]
- He looks so
amazing, [INAUDIBLE]
- I like the artifice.
[LAUGHING]
- What did he say?
- You're welcome.
- And so--
- Well, how do you feel?
- Yeah, what is it--
- As I mentioned
at the beginning,
I think I really
do feel that I'm
exploring another possibility
of myself, a better possibility
maybe.
- I feel very hot.
- What do you think, Robin?
- I'm wearing my own clothes.
These are my clothes.
So I actually feel
kind of ordinary.
I love wearing a tux.
I'll wear a tux
any excuse I get.
So this is very limited
artifice for me.
The face is very new.
But what I can see, like,
I can't see my own face.
So what I can see and
what I can experience
is actually a delight and
not totally unknown to me.
So.
It doesn't feel like artifice.
It feels like me.
But I want to take
this moment to just say
thank you so much to this
troupe and to the producers
and to Gwen in
particular for doing
my makeup, which is amazing.
So I just want to
say thank you for
this extraordinary experience.
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]
- My pleasure.
Thank you.
- We should turn it
over to Hisa, I think.
- It was touch and
go for a moment,
but this bitch is pretty.
[LAUGHING]
- So Hisa, do you
want to wrap up?
We have one more question.
Do you want to--
- Uh, do we want to
take one more question?
Or do you--
- I was going to ask you what
you were thinking right now,
but you already you
just basically--
you already talked about that.
So unless you want to go
out a little bit more.
- No, no, so let
me let me wrap up.
First of all, I want to
echo Robin and really thank,
especially, Gabrielle and Jen
for putting this all together
and bringing, you know,
this fantastic group.
Corey was fantastic.
I mean, not only as an artist
and performing and putting
this together, but this
whole group, I think,
you can really feel the sense
of community that everybody has.
It's expressed in the movie.
But experiencing it live,
I think that was the most,
you know, profound
experience for me.
Becoming a beautiful person,
it's a once-in-a-lifetime
experience.
[LAUGHING]
- You were already
beautiful, bitch.
You were already beautiful.
We just put a wig on it.
- But this experience of
the community, I think,
is really something
very special.
I also want to just thank
Becky Wassarman, Academic
Ventures at Radcliffe.
She put in so much work.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you to you all
for coming tonight.
I hope, at least
some of you will
be able to come to the
conference tomorrow, which
we have another very different,
but fantastic set of speakers
and presentations that
I'm sure will be just as
interesting as this evening.
So thank you very much.
- And we want to just do a
shout out to Becky and Jessica
and the whole AV
crew and everybody
was behind the scenes.
- Steve.
- Steve in security.
- And then thank you
so much Hisa and Robin,
amazing courage,
wonderful volunteers,
and just throwing themselves
fully into the experience
and having us here at Radcliffe.
It was really wonderful.
We're thrilled to be back.
- Yeah, thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]